[Music]
well
this family from michigan they
have a very interesting family
why so the so the mom and the dad
have 14 boys whoa
14 boys no no twins in this mix
wow are they mormon that breaks my
grandma's record not that i know of
um and they recently gave birth to
a daughter wow because they've been
wanting been trying for a daughter the
whole time
well not really i guess i don't know
they just really love having a big
family
is that mom okay when did she started
popping out kids
are they like heavily catholic where
they don't believe in contraception
uh i do think they're religious i don't
know which
religion i know that's like a king's
dream come true
the hand-me-down game is over yeah i
have friends that are filipino and
filipinos are often very heavily
catholic and a lot of them have like
[ __ ] seven or eight brothers and
sisters and their parents aren't even
that old yet they're like middle-aged
whoa yeah the uh the mom and dad they're
45 years old
yeah see so like every year all of their
brothers and sisters are one year apart
because
they get pregnant again right away their
oldest is 28 years old so you do the
math
damn they're [ __ ] that's a lot of
math you do yes they ended up
kids by the time they graduated college
they still graduated college
damn no excuses out there three
yeah get pregnant i don't even know how
they did this damn some people are
really good at multitasking not me
so this is the schwantz the schwanz
whoa they look like
they live in like middle america damn
michigan whoa
so the age gap from the oldest to the
baby is
is like 20 years yeah well the oldest is
28 years old
everyone's the dad i can't even tell in
the middle mom
dad okay so mom is still fertile at 40
something yeah she's they're actually
grandparents now
the third oldest or like or third from
the old
i don't know how to say it but whatever
that kid that guy he ended up having a
baby girl so that was the first girl in
the family
but then that was like two years ago i
think it was and so now
they've recently introduced their own
baby family single-handedly helping the
caucasian
population dude can this family even
hang out during rona or they have to
what are they doing i know right
if they're in california they're like
you got to get rid of four kids
yeah consider two households now or
three four five i like the first picture
with the kid being like i'm a boss
yeah well it looked like he was kind of
mad like
[ __ ] another baby oh yeah and then the
last boy the 14th boy
they named him like his middle name is
sheboygan sheboygan she is a boy again
again wow it's a dad joke no
it's a good story it's a boy her name is
a dad joke
it came from well yeah but that name
it came from so the mom's dad
told her a tale uh which by the way
himself he is a father of 14
as well oh [ __ ] the mom's dad the mom's
dad
and so uh there was this the story that
the dad would say
are they mormon about an i'm not sure
about an american
indian chief who was the father of many
boys the chief believed his last child
would be a girl but when the baby was a
boy the chief named him
sheboygan as in she is a boy again
so then they decided to just have fun
with the 14th
kid um now she has a name like sheborgen
no no this is the 14th boy oh but the
girl
they named her maggie jane
oh what does the grocery bill look like
like if do they all live in the same
house well it seems like some of them
moved out right
well yeah yeah um
that's helpful if you had a farm they do
have a form
oh they got these all of them yeah
they're all gonna
help the farm outdoorsman they actually
have a tv show called
the outdoorsman or 14 outdoorsman or
something and
um but this used to be normal though 14.
my grandma had 10 kids but it the fact
that they're
all boys and they're all single birds
it's a one and twenty thousand something
chance yeah what's your kitchen table
look like
is it just like the [ __ ] harry potter
uh room and they're not
they're not small dudes too man they're
like like they can't
every time they want to go out of you as
a family they have to book the banquet
room
they can't just get a normal table they
have to have like the gigantic ass like
passenger van
but even with the passengers you need
two sometimes like they like the older
kids like they end up riding in their
own car
yeah there's like 600 bucks to go to a
movie
and all right [ __ ] kidding me with
this [ __ ] this is crazy and i imagine
this little girl
think about it the 15th child is a
little girl
she has 14 big brothers oh my god that's
[ __ ] crazy when she dates that guy
doesn't just get his ass beat he gets
like gang
beaten and jumped that's pretty much
my mom's this is maggie jane really my
mom was my mom's the youngest she's the
ten
nine kid not ten she's the tenth kid and
she's the only daughter so nine boys
nine single births of sons and then my
mom popped out my mom also
had uh nine siblings but one passed when
she was a baby so she grew up with eight
oh okay is it a big difference so it's
10 total my mom is a 20-year difference
from
her oldest brother oh [ __ ] no my mom is
like pretty close all right
actually hold on my dad's like that my
dad's a seventh grade has five siblings
and i thought that was a lot
it's not no i think it is like a 20-year
differences or something
yeah i call my own goals by numbers i
just hear like from my relatives that
like
10 plus was pretty average wow all these
it was pretty normal back in the day so
my mom was weird because it was just her
my aunt so this is the whole family with
the girlfriends involved and the girls
that's a freaking university classroom
the new baby
like this is like their entire immediate
family did she gave birth to the dogs
too
yeah oh she also said that the dogs are
boys too
[ __ ] well they had a choice in that so
the holidays must be
crazy i know that's a family reunion
with the immediate
family yeah so then discovering that the
last one was a girl was a surprise
because
they didn't know the gender of the baby
throughout the whole pregnancy
they just assumed the probably assumed
they probably did
that's how it goes wow that's a lot
you're one of those
dude's girlfriends and you got to go
meet everybody like i'll never know all
your names
it's worse than you coming to jk party
for the first time exactly that was the
worst i think
all the in-laws from my family are all
all my cousins who are married like
their significant other said it was very
nerve-wracking to come to our very first
family gathering
because it's like nine of my uncles and
then you got
nine aunts and then you also have their
kids nice oh yeah
damn you got a big family yeah that's
only my mom's side there's something all
in
uh they're all on sf yeah i've never
seen all of my mom's
siblings and kids in one place oh really
never we did that every year not even
for my grandpa's funeral
oh wow wow they're all very close huh no
i mean it's just that
like some of them couldn't go to mexico
because they just couldn't go back to
mexico
and things like that but yeah yeah i'm
surprisingly close to all my cousins
it makes it easier when you live in one
city in one place so we saw each other
i saw one of them every weekend so
that's
cool it's pretty nice [ __ ] my cousins
[ __ ] them all that's what i say you
don't like them nah
i loved hanging with my cousins when we
were younger but the older we got
everyone like moved away
there's people in new mexico and i don't
know where else not old mexico
no the new one okay yeah the new one new
one's kind of cool
[ __ ] my cousins [ __ ] my uncles and [ __ ]
my aunts
all of them and your sister look my
sister is hot i would [ __ ] with you
they all suck though yeah well they all
look they all rsvp
to my wedding and they didn't show so
[ __ ] them all damn that's
even worse i'd rather be like yeah damn
right
because i'd rather be like nah bro come
in exactly save you the money be honest
my sister came and i was like damn i
think i [ __ ] up
mary the wrong girl i was like i wish
she didn't come it made this difficult
on me
that is so weird when you said i do you
looked at her
[Laughter]
i've never seen you i don't think i've
seen you do this bit in front of nikki
what is that like no wait she does that
i do i definitely have
nikki probably gets turned on from it
should i oh yeah i'm gonna be steve's
sister tonight
role play happens that's [ __ ] weird
but anyway you guys want to know the 14
boys name
yeah i'm going to forget them i would i
would run out of names
are they interesting or are they like
maggie yeah is it like jason
jason gayson mason lacy
that'd be kind of cool or is it the
dad's name the second the third the
fourth
that's what i would do if i was a dad
wow henry the ninth
so the mom's name is kateri and the
dad's name is
jay okay that's some interesting names
terry sounds like a game of thrones name
harry and then maggie's the the youngest
right and then there's
tyler zach drew brandon tommy vinnie
calvin gabe wesley charlie
luke tucker francisco and english name
known to man
threw me off cisco all the names are
normal then you got like [ __ ]
sheboygan
tyler zack
they all sounded like super white names
and all that sounds like francis but
then also vinnie
i thought yeah they got italian
yeah huh where are they from michigan
mission dude they're all gonna have kids
and they're all gonna hang out for
christmas and [ __ ] it's gonna be [ __ ]
nuts they're gonna fill stadiums soon
i thought home alone was a big family
you know when the opening scene and you
see that big-ass family this is even
bigger
i know but they say they love it and
they're super happy
and like they wouldn't keep popping out
kids if they didn't love it so
that's great they haven't those parents
like see a picture of them and then also
the aunts and uncles and their families
because
what oh they had like what eight aunts
or some [ __ ] right
no 14. that's huge and uncles
wow they take up the entire state of
michigan
i feel like when you live when you're
not like in the city city it makes this
life
easier to do because of space and the
bigger houses
and all that stuff but like you can't do
the city [ __ ] like go out and eat every
night and all that and
whatever but then if you notice like the
city life you just pop out like one kid
yeah if any like it's really low
yeah that's true because the space and
all that and how you're gonna do all of
it and it's expensive as [ __ ] well also
you're
trying to have like both parts partners
in the couple
trying to have a like a job and career
national career like yeah
and you can't exactly have kids all the
time stressful too which makes it harder
to conceive
i'd rather go outside [ __ ] chop some
wood
and [ __ ] cream pie that sounds like
the life for me pick your eggs in the
morning
that's fresh some eggs and bacon and
inseminate some eggs yup inseminate some
eggs
and pop out some babies dude how do you
even hang out as a couple with that many
kids oh yeah how do they even have the
time to hang out with the kids
yeah it is their dates well which kids
should we bring out tonight or is it
like animal where they start
keeping each other company and then they
don't bother you anymore
oh yeah those kids have definitely heard
their parents having sex
the quarterback for the indianapolis
colts his name is philip rivers he has
12 children
and he goes on the road for like you're
talking about like fall
through winter leaving the wife at home
with 12 kids
that wild who is this philip rivers
quarterback for the colts
used to be chargers long term so he's
got potent sperm
he's always doing touchdowns you got
money though you know he's got money but
they
they always clown on him in the nfl
because he has so many [ __ ] kids like
how do you even know all your kids names
and he's like
i mean kinda wow so yeah he's the
cheaper from a
deeper than a dozen yeah he is and
really totally is
but yeah he's probably rich enough to
make it all work but still man i can't
imagine leaving your wife at home alone
with all those kids
oh no what if you have a team helping
you have to yeah you have to have a team
for that
you